[Music]
[Music]
if you're having tea with a giant hello
kitty doll
then you're almost certainly
in japan
[Music]
this is a place that specializes
in obsessing over things
and taking every want and need to their
unnatural extreme
if you desire a refreshing drink
there's a vending machine that will
evaluate your face and pick the perfect
beverage
[Music]
or
perhaps you prefer to imbibe while in
the company of an ornamental owl
[Music]
or to down a latte with a
three-dimensional robot as garnish
ah that's a good robot
the japanese of course also fetishized
technology like no other culture
[Music]
japan's once glorious tech shine may
have dulled with the decline of sony and
other empires
but without question there's a new tech
movement on the rise
[Music]
i'm traveling from tokyo to kyoto
to meet the japanese inventors bringing
this new culture to life
away we go
along the way
i'll hang with some robots it can kick
my ass
and lose myself in this trippy
wonderland
all on this episode of hello world
[Music]
[Applause]
silicon valley may be home to some of
the biggest tech giants in the world but
it's being challenged like never before
crazy tech geniuses have popped up all
over the planet making things that will
blow your mind
my name is ashley vance i'm an author
and journalist and i'm on a quest to
find the most innovative tech creations
and meet the beautiful freaks behind
them
[Music]
where else would i begin my journey
but in tokyo
[Music]
millions of people make their way around
the city in an orderly fashion
[Music]
doing their best not to bother anyone
the hustle of modern life dominates the
city
but
it's at night that tokyo really comes to
life
welcome to the robot restaurant
[Music]
as touristy and insane as all of this is
it actually gets to the heart of japan's
relationship with robots
[Music]
the machines here come with stories and
personality
they're good
they're bad
and sometimes they eat people
but far away from the fire-breathing
dinosaurs
and werewolf guitarists
researchers at a tokyo museum have set
up a workshop
where they're looking to prove that
robots can be imbued with life hello
eat your red pill
and try to keep up
[Music]
professor takashi ikegami has helped
create this thing
which looks like it comes straight from
ex machina central casting
through a series of sensors and
artificial intelligence software
this android looks out into the world
and reacts to what it sees
the android is in effect evolving
based on what its ai software seems to
like
basically there are two different
mechanisms one is um autonomous
algorithm generators okay it's coupled
with each other
also there's artificial neural networks
spontaneously firing and sending signals
to each other
[Music]
as someone approaches the android the
sensors detect the movement
and then the software kicks in
to determine how the robot will move in
response
[Music]
but
for the moment
it has a movement style that could be
described as that really drunk guy at
the party okay so in each one of these
sensor boxes right here yes there's two
cameras yep and this is measuring the
measuring the distance yes so when i
come closer or further away from the
machine then robot has to do something
it has to do react to that yeah you guys
will add more and more sensors yeah you
can put like temperature sensors sound
sensors many other sensors
armed with more sensors the robot can
make more judgments about its
environment
and more nuanced reactions
over time the movements and gurgles
change
the thinking is that the robot will
eventually form its own personality
and possibly even language
what's the deal with the noise is it
hungry
this sound is designed by
my student
that behavior is modifying those sounds
the sound is changing all the time
it's more like you know a primitive
language that's i think the interesting
part of it like our babies we don't have
to tell everything to the baby but baby
can learn unconsciously by interacting
with people
with the environment right
[Music]
once we have a bunch of lifelike systems
around us maybe our concept of what is
life will be very much different
and then if we want to coexist with
robots then we maybe have to learn
different languages
different way of thinking
[Music]
so that doesn't freak you out you think
that's
i think it's much more ideal to me
comparing with
this you know very
violent world right now
[Music]
well thank you for letting me see your
android thank you
thank you
oh she said something
i think he said he likes you
[Music]
[Applause]
if you want to learn about robot culture
kyoto is as good of a place to start as
any
[Applause]
for hundreds of years it has been the
showcase city for japan's most famous
traditions
from geishas
to spectacular temples
over in the university district you can
also find some of japan's best
technological minds i've come to
doshisha university to dive deep into
japan's love affair with robots with a
professor and one of japan's most active
robot hobbyists
[Music]
[Music]
wow
yeah akira's got good moves
embodies a japanese concept known as
otaku
it refers to a person who obsesses over
something
be it hello kitty
sushi
or robots
for takashi robotics is more than a
hobby it's his passion
most of his free time goes into
assembling these things by hand out of
3d printed body parts and electronics
do you work on these almost every day
yes
about two hours almost every day
that's cool
each one takes months to build including
the software for the choreographed moves
but it's not all for show
these robots must fight to earn their
key akira would hit other robots
one of takashi's robots recently took
first place in a competition
making him
king of the otaku
[Music]
and when you're the king
there are people that want to study you
one of japan's foremost researchers into
the relationship between man and bots is
hirofumi katsuno an anthropologist here
at toshisha university
i was looking for you know the
passionate people who work on robots i
joined the group and started uh to
create my own robots and youtube met at
these in the events
hiro felt compelled to ask that
seinfeldian question
what's the deal with japan and all those
robots
it's related to japan's sort of national
quest
to establish its own identity
after the world war ii
so after the sort of devastation of the
whole land
japan started to
rebuild the nation
through promoting the peaceful use of
science and technology
in that process i think many uh anime
creators and manga creators started to
ponder the kind of ideal relationship
between the japanese and technology for
instance like tisca
some
hiro is not alone in pointing to the
significance of astro boy
the manga series started in the 1950s
and has a mad scientist type building an
android to replace his dead son
the saga goes on to explore what life
would be like if humans and robots
coexist
and it's that very same idea that one
local tech giant has invested millions
of dollars to pursue
[Music]
[Laughter]
hitachi produces a shocking amount of
stuff from brain scanners right on up to
nuclear reactors
this being japan
it's also in the robot game
i've gone to one of the company's
vaunted research labs to see its latest
take on the robot that people desire
most
an autonomous helper
hitachi calls this creature emu
hello everyone
i'm very happy to meet you
emu was developed as a sort of friendly
robot concierge equipped with ai for
navigation and speech recognition
he might provide directions at an
airport or do some low-level security
work
or he might be kicked over by a cynical
reporter looking for a good time
that's pretty cool
that resemblance between emu and my pal
hello kitty is on purpose
emu's designer asi baba wanted the robot
to have the same harmless non-creepy
feel
is it meant to look like a child yes
because everyone
like it
everyone likes child yeah fair enough
there's an adorable quality to these
robots and they may be helpful one day
for the moment though
rolling around looking cute is about the
extent of what they can do
and they're super expensive to make
do you have a price that you're aiming
to get to we replied to you know cheaper
car
be cheaper than a car come okay
what's that emu
you want to make up for your failings by
showing me an autonomous vehicle
okay
thanks heavier
here's my ride
this sweet hog with the flip top door is
called ropitz
away we go
it's sort of like a self-driving car but
is meant to travel down sidewalks
instead of on the road
and this is the vehicle's inventor ryoki
hichonosis
japan's aging population has forced the
country to try and invent new ways to
help seniors make their way around
cities
the idea here is that someone can summon
the car to their house
and then go for a leisurely drive to the
store
the open windows and slow speed of
ropets means that the driver can even
have a chat with a friend
or perhaps an emmy walking nearby
[Applause]
it's a beautiful utopian future hitachi
is imagining for us all
full of smart compassionate robots
attending to our every need
but suffice it to say
that future very much remains the future
the wall the wall the wall
where are we going
where are we going
what's going on robot
helping you
japan's creative thinking has stalled in
recent years as its tech giants and
startups have struggled
[Music]
to find out why i joined my friend
noriaki okubo back in tokyo for a chat
about japan's tech scene over noodles
aki is a well-connected tech guru
venture capitalist and champion noodle
slurper
i've never worked on my slurp technique
after a week in japan
i had so many questions for him how
would you compare the japanese vc scene
to say silicon valley
traditional vcs are really
bad because they don't want to take
risks
there's a lot of new vcs that are doing
pretty well new internet companies and
you know they can take risk but not the
traditional you know salaryman type vcs
[Music]
when aki says salary man he's talking
about that image we have of the
conservative hard-working japanese
businessman
this culture rewards conformity and safe
business decisions
according to aki it's a key factor in
the fall of japan's tech dominance in
favor of the disruptive mentality of
silicon valley
the decisions that come up from that
kind of process is always going to be
you know let's just do something that's
okay and nothing cool yeah
is there a big call to change that way
of thinking i mean i think there is but
it's just still very the minority yeah
walaki's take on technology here holds
true in the big picture
there are plenty of people and companies
that see themselves as rebels trying to
buck the system
and no one exemplifies this better than
toshiyuki onoko and his company team lab
for inoco
struck when he was just eight years old
[Music]
in my second year of junior high
i usually tell people that an electric
wave struck me
i'm not sure what it actually was or
even how to describe this but
a strong sense of duty that i needed to
do something that had meaning in society
suddenly came over me
if that red pill is still circulating
through your system
then this will feel perfect
let's see if we can go find a fish
[Music]
it's one of team labs world famous
techno art experiences
they use this projection mapping
technology
to track the fish
when they hit somebody's
body supposed to turn into a flower
all right we're supposed to move on
let's go down the hallway
how long does it take to do one of these
projects not
forever
we take one idea and create
reconsider then repeat the process
[Music]
for example the exhibit you saw crystal
universe
we've been working on for five years
the pool one
we've been working on for two to three
years
team lab has around 400 employees
thinking up new
ever weirder things and working in their
makeshift laboratories what's this one
[Music]
you're making clothes right
i think it's for a show
it's for a dancer
no he's making clothes for a mascot
here we're experimenting with a device
that allows you to manipulate waves in
the water you're gonna make patterns in
the water and control the patterns yeah
that's cool
[Music]
this is the
inoko is known throughout japan as a
flamboyant character
for him you either create something new
where you grow old and stay quiet
[Music]
japanese society has aged too much
it is a society of old people
it's conservative and it can't seek
value in new things so you're trying to
change that no no no
no no no no no i want to be with people
who want to take a step into the new
world
people who are creative
who want to change the world
these people i hope to inspire to have
an influence on
or
by having them experience our art
i want to shake their values
so rather than taking on people who
don't want change
i work to inspire people who want change
[Music]
it's a noco and the people wired like
him the two seem to be japan's best hope
for a major technology resurgence
the well-funded robotics labs and
corporate giants do amazing research
but they've struggled to keep pace with
places like silicon valley and china
when it comes to making products that
actually reach consumers
japan remains trapped between two worlds
the old
and the new
it's a country that has turned the
future into a religion but that must
still deal with an aging population and
rigid customs
the way forward for japan its chance to
really make a mark will almost certainly
come from its robots
emu for one is already getting ready to
be a guide and chauffeur at the 2020
olympics
[Music]
for now
i say good night to japan
may all our dreams be filled with hello
kitty
[Music]
up next on hello world
i head to russia
to fly drones in siberia
hang with a techno oligarch wow it's
really cool and get beaten with a birch
branch